the Covington kids sue the Washington
Post for a quarter of a billion dollars
crooked X FBI official Andy McCabe walks
back comments on the coup d'etat that he
helped plan
New York's Bolshevik Mayor Bill DeBlasio
attacks Ocasio Cortes as too far left
and Kamala Harris's own father attacks
her too for cynically playing identity
politics we asked has the left finally
gone too far I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
this is a day that we have all been
waiting for
after weeks of the left going completely
insane we've wondered is there a limit
to this is there any point that they can
reach where members of their own party
will push back where the American people
will push back I think we have reached
it and we have reached it explicitly
today all of the evidence shows a major
push back not just from Howard Schultz
although he's part of it but four
members of the Democrat Party from
left-wingers from Bolsheviks like Bill
DeBlasio we'll go through all of it but
first let's make a little money honey
with Dollar Shave Club I love that
Dollar Shave Club has everything I need
to look feel and smell my best what I
love even more is that I never have to
go to the store that's because Dollar
Shave Club delivers everything that I
need right to my door and they keep me
fully stocked on what I use so I don't
run out here's how it works
they have everything you need to get
ready no matter what you're getting
ready for they have you covered head to
toe your hair your skin your face you
name it they have this new program where
they automatically keep you stocked up
on the products that you use for
instance look at my shiny beautiful
teeth look at those teeth you see that
you need good toothpaste and this is one
of those things I always forget to go to
the store to buy toothpaste so you're
there at the very end of the tube
squeezing out you know one hundredths of
a cent worth of toothpaste until the
very end or II or sometimes I hate to be
a little behind the curtain here on this
sometimes you don't even you just try to
brush as best you can with the remnants
scraps of toothpaste don't do that no
more get that beautiful Dollar Shave
Club toothpaste it gets automatically
sent to you it's just fabulous right now
they've got a bunch of starter sets you
can try for just five bucks like their
oral care kit after that the restock box
ships regular size products at regular
price what are you waiting for get your
store set for just five bucks right now
five bucks that's like nothing go to
dollarshaveclub.com slash cough fa ce
o-- v fe fe that is dollarshaveclub.com
slash cough fa c OV e f e f e so the
first bit of evidence that the left has
gone too far and we're not going to take
it anymore
comes in the form of those covington
high school kids you remember the kids
waiting for their bus outside in
Washington a bunch of black supremacist
starts screaming at them that Native
American lunatic walks up and starts
banging
kids face kid does nothing other than
sort of smile a little bit and the whole
mainstream media the whole left-wing
Democrat presidential candidates they
all pile on the kid they say that he ran
up to them he was provoking them he that
totally smear this kid Nick Sandman he
is fighting back he is now suing the
Washington Post for a quarter of a
billion dollars ha ha ha happy day it's
so good I'm not the only one celebrating
president Trump himself is celebrating
and I gotta tell you that I have been
waiting over three years for this tweet
president Trump tweeted quote The
Washington Post ignored basic
journalistic standards because it wanted
to advance its well known and easily
documented biased agenda against
President Donald J Trump Covington's
students suing wopo go get them Nick
fake news I have been waiting over three
years for this tweet I have been waiting
three years ever since Barack Obama
tweeted out to that kid who had it was I
guess sort of like a bomb hoax in his
school from this is the son of this
activist radical activist and the kid
brought in what looked like a bomb but
it was a disassembled clock that he
didn't even build he just sort of took
apart part of a clock and Barack Obama
weighs in on this and he you obviously
is in favor of the radical left here any
tweets cool clock Achmed want to bring
it to the White House we should inspire
more kids like you to like science it's
what makes America great and we just sat
there and we thought you jerk Barack
Obama
you have to just needle all of America
all the time imply that Americans are
racist implied that they are
irrationally religiously bigoted it just
mm-hmm just twist that little knife and
we have been waiting now for over three
years for the answer and we got the
answer and the answer wasn't because
some guy made a clock or whatever it was
not know the answer was because a high
school kid
is suing wopo for a quarter of a billion
dollars go get them Nick fake news ha ha
ha how's it feel it feel left-wing
America has it feel Washington Post oh
it's so good it's the perfect response
revenge is a dish best tweeted three
years later when you might take down
that stupid fake newspaper in The
Washington Post I'm enjoying this so
much that it takes a while to come back
and ask the question does the kid have a
case I don't really care if he does or
not just love this lawsuit but it'd be
better obviously if he does have a case
and the evidence points to the Covington
kid Nick Sandman actually having a
defamation case against the Washington
Post why why does he I mean it's very
hard to prove defamation or libel or
slander or calumny it's very difficult
because you have to show intent you have
to show recklessness you have to show
that they were ignoring certain things
Alan Dershowitz one of the leading
lawyers in the whole country for the
past 40 years 50 years believes that
these kids have a case the lawsuit
claims that the Washington Post quote
ignored the truth and falsely accused
Nicolas of among other things a costing
in quotes Phillips by suddenly swarming
him in a threatening and physically
intimidating manner now did the
Washington Post just get the story wrong
because then I don't know if they have a
case is does this very language
constitute of defamation in and of
itself well I don't know how does a 16
year old kid appear physically
threatening the kid I mean not I don't
mean to criticize the kid at all he's
not the most physically intimidating guy
to begin with is he intimidating him
because he's sort of smiling well some
lunatic is banging a drum in his face
that's not threatening but when was he
threatening him when did they suddenly
swarm there was no evidence whatsoever
that they suddenly swarmed none at all
The Washington Post invented that out of
whole cloth how do we know that because
the short video that was first released
didn't show
and then the longer video obviously
didn't show that instead you had the
Native American lunatic and the black
supremacists swarming the kids the
Native American or the the black
supremacist screaming at the kids
starting the confrontation and then the
Native American lunatic physically going
up to the kids and banging a drum in
their face that's obviously more
threatening than smirking banging a drum
and some kids face instead of just just
a little assault smirk a hate smirk now
the salmon attorney goes on further and
this is like the best part of it quote
all members of the mainstream and social
media mob of bullies who recklessly and
viciously attacked Nick would be
well-served to read it carefully
referring to the lawsuit now the
language here was very precise and it
was intentional all these other members
of the media as well as these online
celebrities presidential candidates
would be well-served to read it
carefully as in served with a lawsuit so
this clearly is a legal threat what it
seems to imply I hope it's not an empty
threat what it seems to imply is that
Sandman is going to be going after other
people as well who piled on him good I
hope so I hope he takes these people for
all they're worth
I hope he rips the Washington Post to
the ground the Washington Post is
already a journalistic pile of rubble
and they should empty out that building
as well they should empty out the
payroll as well they should empty out
the corporate structure as well and that
way you can have the corporate structure
match the journalistic standards that
they adhere to which is absolute ruins
same thing with the Democrat
presidential candidates same thing
with the online celebrities it's
fabulous in New York City Alexandria ok
Jie Cortez has gone too far left as well
how do we know that it's not just the
Washington Post it's not just these
online celebrities AOC has gone too far
left even for the Bolshevik Mayor Bill
DeBlasio Bill DeBlasio bill de blasio
was interviewed on NBC News and he was
asked about the Amazon deal Alexandria
Ocasio Court has almost single-handedly
chased Amazon out of New York this would
have this destroyed 40
jobs the jobs with an average salary of
$150,000 a ton of tax revenue from that
borough from that neighborhood going
into the city going into the state or
even lefty lunatics like de Blasio were
begging for Amazon to come there and
okay as CEO Cortez chased them out here
is Bill de Blasio trying to walk this
tightrope between not going explicitly
after aoc but also saying look we we
progressives we Democrats are not anti
job we do please don't get the wrong
impression please don't think that we're
chasing John I mean they are the leading
spokesman for progressivism right now
Alexandria o Cassio Cortes is explicitly
saying we don't need your jobs we don't
need your money we don't need your
productive economy and you think nonono
don't believe that here he's trying to
make the case he opens up his NBC
interview he says before we get to
anything well Chuck it's great to be
here but I'm a progressive and I'm proud
to be progressives are about jobs for
working people so that's an essential
progressive value it isn't though I see
why he has to make that case because the
left has been exposed the left is
exposed itself but jobs for working
people is not a progressive value the
progressive value is not about helping
out the poor the progressive value is
about hurting the rich this has always
been true we've always known this to be
true but they have exposed themselves in
this Amazon deal the Amazon deal which
would have cost the city nothing it
would have cost them three billion
dollars out of 20 in tax incentives out
of an additional twenty seven billion
dollars in tax revenue that they were
going to get would have created tens of
thousands of jobs an enormous amount of
wealth that forget about just tax
receipts to the state and local
governments it just the wealth that this
would have created for New York would
have been immense and they gave all of
that up on the ideology of progressivism
because by helping the working class and
the middle class in New York it would
have also helped the rich and Alexandria
cassio Cortes and her fellow
progressives cannot abide that they
would rather hurt the rich than help the
poor it is
Winston Churchill said socialism is the
creed of ignorance the gospel of envy
and the philosophy of failure that's
what it is Margaret Thatcher said you
don't care you would rather the
difference in wealth between the rich
and the poor be smaller even if
everybody got poorer then for the
difference in wealth between the rich
and the poor to increase even if
everyone gets richer we've been making
this point for decades now AOC is
spelling it out de Blasio is still
trying to keep a lid on it
she also exposes herself for not
understanding anything about economics I
don't mean that she doesn't understand
some advanced aspect of economics some
contentious part I mean she doesn't
understand even what attacks is she
doesn't even know what taxes are we'll
show that clip in a second and we'll
show de Blasio trying to talk about it
trying to walk it back but first we do
understand money here we do understand
how money works let's make a little
money honey with honey
millions of top-rated sellers are
offering the exact same products on
Amazon finding the best deal feels like
looking for an invisible needle in the
world's biggest haystack
thanks to honey the free browser
extension I always get the best price on
Amazon without lifting a finger
honey automatically goes to work
whenever I shop on Amazon it compares
the prices of every seller that carries
the item that I want honey factors in
shipping sales tax and Amazon Prime
status to make sure I'm getting the
lowest total price it makes the best
deal every time even if Amazon doesn't
it's like having your very own personal
shopping assistant I got this just the
other day I was buying a Valentine's Day
present for sweet little ELISA and I was
going on Amazon you know you're looking
at all that different prices and
everything and different different
people selling the same product you just
don't know you don't need to worry about
that with honey you go - honey honey
will track the price for you it will
show you other sellers that have it I
was able to get the cheapest price on
sweet little Elise's air pots and
they're very cool I love it saves I mean
I've been using honey since before the
daily wire exists and I've saved
thousands of dollars on it more than ten
million people are using honey to save
money has an over a hundred thousand
five-star reviews on the chrome store
it's it's free money next time you're
shopping on Amazon don't wonder whether
you found the best deal just add honey
get the best price automatically add
honey for free at join honey
/ cough FAC OV e fe fe that is join
honey
dot-com / cough fa co v of e fe honey
the smart shopping assistant that helps
save you time and money honey so
alexandria casio cortez this is the clip
that de blasio it has to react to good
on Chuck Todd actually for playing it
alexandria casio cortez is talking she's
celebrating how she chased amazon out of
New York yeah we got rid of 40,000 jobs
woohoo we did it progressivism for the
win and Chuck Todd has to play this clip
for Bill DeBlasio he has a tough answer
but just listen to how this woman
misunderstands taxes willing to give
Amazon 3 with we're willing to give away
3 billion dollars for this deal we could
invest those 3 billion dollars in our
district ourselves if we wanted to we
could hire out more teachers we can fix
our subways we can put a lot of people
to work for that money if we wanted to
no you can't because the money doesn't
exist I cannot believe this makes total
sense now I mean this is why she I guess
just pure ignorance coupled with her
ideology caused her to fight and get rid
of 40,000 jobs in her district the three
billion dollars does not exist New York
said that they would give three billion
dollars in tax incentives to Amazon if
they put their headquarters there a tax
incentive is a rebate on the taxes that
you pay so in order to get the three
billion dollars in tax incentives you
have to pay at least three billion
dollars in the first place if that
revenue isn't there revenue to the
government you don't get the tax
incentive dude she thinks there's just
like three billion dollars sitting
around on 15th Street just waiting to be
picked up and doled out to everybody no
no no Amazon provides the money from
which the that includes and compasses
the three billion dollars so if there's
no Amazon there's no three billion this
girl has a degree in economics from
Boston University Boston University
should shut down
we should shudder we should decertify
Boston University if you can get a
degree in economics from Boston
University and not understand what a tax
is that university should not exist
people should I mean certainly no one
should send their children there if they
want to study economics because even if
you if you know you could learn
economics there look at how low the
standards have fallen so she doesn't
understand what the basic tax is by the
way the entire role of Congress is to
control the purse strings as her she's a
congresswoman doesn't understand the
very basics of taxes here bill de blasio
tries to explain without going after her
too hard what a tax incentive is people
think that when you give a tax incentive
that that somehow that's oh that's money
you had over here and it was going over
there these were this is money that
didn't exist this three hundred dollars
okay is that do you feel as if this is a
problem in trying to explain how this
deal worked yeah look this was a deal
that was gonna bring 27 billion dollars
in revenue to the state and city for
things like public education mass
transit affordable housing and that
three billion dollars would go back in
tax incentives was only after we were
getting the jobs and getting there's not
three billion dollars and nobody's
anywhere correct exactly so here's the
bottom line I think people were looking
for fairness here they were looking for
a positive outcome okay so he died says
well no yeah it's not no she's done not
quite but he won't go after her
specifically why not because she's
influenced your old nationally and he
keeps saying look I'm defining
progressivism no progressivism is Pro
jobs it's Pro worker know you're not in
the really the way that we know that you
are not the spokesman for progressivism
is that you won't criticize aoc who just
lost your city twenty seven billion
dollars in tax revenue 40,000 jobs
average jobs of $150,000 you won't go
after her because she is popular
nationally she is a far more widely
known spokesman for progressivism than
Bill DeBlasio is and this is what
happens by the way when you follow AOC
and you are factually incorrect but
morally right there's no such thing as
that she said the other day some people
they're so obsessed with being factually
correct that they're not morally right
in order to be morally right you have to
be factually correct
what aoc just did is immoral she
deprived that district of 40 thousand
jobs a ton of money a ton of wealth and
she did it because she was factually
incorrect she didn't know what a tax was
she thought that the city was gonna
spend three billion dollars to bring
Amazon their three billion that they
could have invested in the people no no
that money doesn't exist they were just
gonna take three billion dollars of less
out of twenty seven billion dollars that
was going to go to the city and anyway
so we know that this is not the first
time that AOC has demonstrated her
economic illiteracy her factual
incorrectness Ben Stein here he is
making that point just the other day
Medicare for all that means we're going
to have bankruptcy for all look miss
Cortez has a plan to do it together get
out of rebuilding of this country it's
gonna bankrupt this country it's gonna
make this country literally bankrupt if
the green green New Deal we're ever
signed into law on that day the American
people would be bankrupt forever so it's
a very very serious step we've got to
step back we went way way WAY far back
bankrupt forever and he's not
exaggerating he's not joking forty
trillion dollars instantly you killed
the entire economy you take over whole
industries that would bankrupt us
forever
that would be Venezuela people think
Venezuela could never happen here the
way Venezuela happens here is the green
New Deal quote unquote the Democrats
weren't always like this Democrats have
passed big radical spending packages in
the past hasn't totally destroyed our
country what's different now is the
degree it's not different in kind
they were always pretty radical they
were always spending a lot of money they
were always economically largely
illiterate but with what's happened now
is they have gone so far to the left
that you're talking about not just
hampering the economy for four or eight
years you're talking about bankrupting
us forever when you talk about the green
New Deal when you have gone further left
than Bill DeBlasio you are through the
looking glass and it's not just in New
York it's not just on economic matters
nationally speaking
Andy McCabe the guy who tried to launch
a coup d'etat on president Donald Trump
has now gone too far even for some
Democrats he's gone too far he's pushed
the left too far and so now he's got to
walk back I remember we did a whole show
on disgraced FBI agent Andy McCabe's
attempted coup d'etat we went through
point by point what he said now he's
walking that back because he admitted to
treason all to sell a book he admitted
to being a traitor to his country listen
to how the exposed liar
the demonstrably liar Andy McCabe
contradicts his previous statements that
he made just a few days ago he's
contradicting them now yesterday on
MSNBC discussing the 25th amendment
which removes a duly elected president
from office the conversation was not
about removing the president well that's
what the 25th amendment is so rod bring
brought up the 25th amendment mentioned
it in the course of a wide-ranging and
frenetic conversation it is not
something that I'm aware of he took any
action to pursue I don't know about any
other meetings that included discussions
of it
it was simply one thing one topic in the
midst of a whole host of issues that we
were thinking about and kind of working
through our heads is he present that
idea to other cabinet officials because
as you know he had to count heads to see
do I have the votes to remove the
president not that I'm aware of I've no
education no not that I'm aware no
indication that he was counting the
votes no indication whatsoever except
that three days ago he said that rod
Rosen Stein was counting the votes other
cabinet members and whether or not
people would support such an idea
whether or not other cabinet members
would shared his belief that the
president was was really concerning
what's concerning rod at that time
Rosenstein was actually openly talking
about whether there was a majority of
the cabinet who would vote to remove the
president that's correct
counting votes or possible votes he
explicitly uses the phrase yes he was
counting vote but I mean we know that we
know that this guy is a liar he got
fired from the FBI for being a lot
but we know at the very beginning of his
interview the one on MSNBC he said no no
we weren't talking about removing the
president we were just talking about the
25th amendment and then good on the
MSNBC panel they said uh the entire
point of the 25th Furman amendment is to
remove the president yeah yeah but we
were no but that was part of a
wide-ranging discussion right I don't
care if you were talking about your
favorite apple pie recipe you were
talking about it you were talking about
it you just said you were talking about
it then you said you weren't talking
about it now you're admitting you were
talking about it but this guy is a liar
I mean his words are worth nothing which
is why we've got to investigate what
he's really doing and you got to
remember when it when this guy was found
to have lied to investigators the
Inspector General turned his case over
to the US Attorney for possible
prosecution and also good on CNN CNN
legal analyst Ellie Hoenig who's
probably not going to be a CNN legal
analyst for long he came out and he came
out strongly against Andy McCabe and now
we've got to look at potential
prosecution whenever we hear something
from McCain we need to keep in mind he
has a serious credibility problem the
Department of Justice inspector general
found that he lacked candor which is the
polite bureaucratic way of saying lied
three times in three separate interviews
about whether he was a leak or
authorized the leak on the Hillary
Clinton case and he made it he's made a
defense during this book tour well I was
confused and I didn't understand the
questions I find that completely
unconvincing he lied not just he didn't
just have one bad day three separate
times lied to the FBI and also said he
was authorized by the FBI to be the
person who was the liaison with the
press you don't buy that the DOJ the OIG
certainly did not buy it and look Paul
Manafort Michael Flynn Michael Cohen
George papadopolis we're all prosecutors
making false statements to federal
investigators
I don't see why McCabe's case is really
any different than those boom absolutely
right this is the issue you've got
Michael Flynn thrown under the bus
looking at prison for what for maybe
making a misleading statement to an
investigator you've got all of these
Paul Manafort is basically going to jail
for enjoying nice suits in the 1990s and
you've got all of these
guys all facing charges for lying to
investigators
Andy McCabe lied to investigators the
Inspector General point set out so all
things being equal all these guys lied
to investigators now what's the
difference one of them is a lying about
inconsequential things another one is
basically just likes nice Italian suits
yeah but some of these guys they're
lying about things maybe or misleading
or maybe misremembering things in an
investigation that really shouldn't have
been happening in the first place
launched by the way by Andy McCabe and
then in the other case you've got Andy
McCabe who is attempting to launch a
coup d'etat and overturn a u.s.
presidential election those are not
equal their crimes ostensibly are equal
but I guess there's another way in which
they're unequal all of the people
working for Republicans have to go to
jail to pay for that crime and Andy
McCabe gets to smile smile on television
news on MSNBC what did I do wrong I did
nothing wrong by my book give me your
money
unbel who is not only a demonstrable
liar he's lying right in front of us
he's telling us don't believe our lying
eyes and our lying ears I really hope
that guy gets prosecuted I really hope
that they follow up on that because
maasai niveau that that Andy McCabe this
guy working for a crony leftist
bureaucratic coup d'etat has gone too
far left
even for MSNBC and even for CNN this is
a sign of some sanity in the country and
speaking of presidential coup d'etats
speaking of the presidency in the
Democrat presidential primary you now
have Kamala Harris who's probably the
leader of the pack she's probably the
strongest candidate right now going too
far left even for her own father who has
come out and attacked her for this we'll
get to that in a second then we got to
get to good ol crazy Bernie we got to
get to the wall and if we have time we
have to get to a new song that is out
about celebrating abortion the left
showing their radicalism killing babies
after birth a new song out about having
a shower a baby shower for the baby that
you're killing
we'll get to all that but first we've
got to say goodbye to Facebook in
YouTube listen I'm gonna be flying out
to Indiana a bit in about two hours and
then I'm gonna be giving a speech
tomorrow night at Notre Dame Notre Dame
right now has beautiful murals of
Christopher Columbus on its walls and
the president of that university has
decided to cover up those murals he
would probably would have taken them
down except they're right on the wall so
they would have had to go full Taliban
and just knock the wall down if they
wanted to get rid of them destroy them
completely so now they're covering them
up I will be going to Notre Dame
tomorrow to discuss how awful this is
what this means for liberal education
the total cowardice and moral idiocy of
the Notre Dame administration and then I
will be presenting a robust defense of
Christopher Columbus hero not heathen
one of the greatest men in all of
history so we're gonna be streaming that
here if you're not in Indiana you don't
want to brave the cold if you are in
Indiana I hope you can come and check it
out it should be a lot of fun we've got
a number of antifa have already RSVP'd I
don't I don't know how open-minded
they're gonna be about hearing my talk
but they apparently will be there
nonetheless and you can check it out on
Daley wire also subscribe ten bucks um
100 dollars for an annual membership you
get me at the end reclaim and show you
get the Ben Shapiro sir you have those
questions the mailbag get to ask
questions backstage you get to ask oh by
the way get your mailbag questions in
for tomorrow you get another Kingdom you
get everything and you get this the
leftist tears tumblr it's gonna be a
little frozen tomorrow in Notre Dame but
it is gonna fill up while we defend the
man who discovered America one of the
greatest men in human history
Christopher Columbus check it out at
daily wire.com we'll be right back with
a lot more
Kamala Harris is in trouble with daddy
so you remember the other day on the
show Kamala Harris was talking about
smoking pot and she said well you know
I'm Jamaican I've smoked pot I love
listening to Tupac and and Snoop Dogg I
did that in college seven years before
Tupac and Snoop Dogg released their
debut albums I'm cool
how do you do fellow kids so she's
talking about then she one of the lines
she said was I'm Jamaican so of course I
like pot hahaha her Jamaican father
didn't get a kick out of that
her father Donald Harris is a Stanford
economics professor and you'll recall at
the time when she came out and talked
about that I said that I doubt that
Kamala Harris has ever smoked pot in her
life I seriously doubt that she has ever
even once taken even one hit on even one
joint because she comes from a pretty
uptight family to a cancer researcher
mother Stanford economics professor
father obviously a very driven woman it
probably in college which he was doing
was studying for law school and then
when she was in law school she was
preparing to become a prosecutor and
then a United States Senator I don't
think she was spending a lot of time
with the choom gang maybe I'm wrong so
her father comes and basically says this
Donald Harris came in and said quote I
won't do it in a Jamaican accent because
that would be slightly too offensive and
he would be maybe funny but I really
liked the point that he's making and I
think he's underscoring the utter
silliness of Kamala Harris's campaign he
says quote my dear departed grandmother
as well as my deceased parents must be
turning in their grave right now to see
their family's name reputation and proud
Jamaican identity being connected in any
way jokingly or not with the fraudulent
stereotype of a pot-smoking joy seeker
and in the pursuit of identity politics
speaking for myself in my media Jamaican
family we wish to categorically
dissociate ourselves from this travesty
Oh tough words from a father about a
daughter but Kamala Harris does deserve
it
Kamala Harris
the whole campaign again I've been
calling this since day one the only
chance she has to win the presidency is
to play identity politics to create a
mood to appeal to people's base
appetites and base bigotry that's the
only chance she has she's an
accomplished woman she's obviously
pretty smart but she can't talk about
any of her accomplishments because she's
a prosecutor and the Democrats had
become lawless they hate prosecutors
they hate cops
they hate law enforcement they hate the
law so she can talk about that and she's
got to pretend that she's a big pot head
cuz haha I'm Jamaican haha I love Snoop
Doggy dog yeah yeah guys I'm a cool kid
that's what yesterday or not I love that
her father called her out for this and
called her and not just for the
offensiveness to Jamaicans but for
playing identity politics so I'll take
that as some validation that even Kamala
Harris's father agrees with my
assessment of her presidential campaign
and she's not the craziest person in the
race you know who the craziest person is
there in the races we now officially
have Bernie Sanders 2020 bit Bernie is
here we played the clip yesterday his
announcement video but only today did we
get president Trump's crazy Bernie tweet
he took prison from tweeted out crazy
bernie has entered the race I wish him
well he gave him that title not the most
clever title but that's okay it's fairly
accurate now this is the counterexample
bernie is entering the race is the
counter example to my thesis that the
left has finally gone too far that the
left is finally seeing pushback from
Howard Schultz from Kamala Harris's
father from MSNBC and CNN analysts from
all of these various people the counter
example to this that people are raising
is that Bernie Sanders in just one day
of announcing his presidential run
raised six million dollars it's a lot of
money that breaks records I mean that is
a huge deal it's not actually a
counterexample though I still I think
this if anything this is evidence that
the left has gone too far let's not
forget that Ron Paul in 2007 raised 4.2
million
in one day that was a dozen years ago he
raised a significant amount of money
also broke fundraising records do we
remember the Paul administration do we
remember those eight years of President
Ron Paul I don't think so when Ron Paul
always was able to raise a ton of money
he was or he was always winning straw
polls at places like CPAC Bernie Sanders
is the Ron Paul of the left now I prefer
Ron Paul to Bernie Sanders by a longshot
because Ron Paul is the Bernie Sanders
of the right and I prefer that but Bert
that's what Bernie Sanders is doing he's
making a huge show of force
he's showing there is a radical leftist
base they're willing to give him a lot
of money they're willing to make big
stunts like one day money bombs or straw
polls because they're not going to be
able to win states they're not going to
be able to survive we explained why
yesterday in a long analysis of his
presidential run he can't survive in a
race of Kamala Harris's he can't survive
in a race where he doesn't have Hillary
Clinton to kick around anymore so
president Trump weighs in on crazy
Bernie that's fine let's remember this
isn't just some epithet that President
Trump is throwing out Bernie Sanders is
a radical socialist he had his honeymoon
in the Soviet Union he sang communist
songs with Soviets shirtless
he has never held a real job in his life
Bernie is so radical that he has
defended bread lines in communist
countries and in leftist countries
throughout his career here is Bernie
Sanders giving away the whole game just
like Alexandria o kzo Cortez he's
pulling away the facade and he's
exposing progressivism for what it is
the ideology of the bread lines is the
economic problems of Nicaragua are not
unique from Central America or in the
third world in fact as poor as Nicaragua
is one of the nice things that I saw is
that as a result of government policy
direct government policy in terms of the
distribution of food people are not
hungry by and large I think it's fair to
say you know it's funny sometimes
American
talk about how bad the country is
because people are lining up for food
that's a good thing in other countries
people don't line up food the rich get
the food and the poor spark to death in
Nicaragua people are not starving to
death
it's a good thing when people line up
for food thread lines are a very good
thing it means they're getting their
food no it means they're not getting
their food that's why they have to wait
in lines for hours if there was plenty
of food to go around they wouldn't be
waiting in line they'd just be doling
out bread hey you go hey who wants a
chicken pot pie hey you'd be going
through the drive-thru like happens in
capitalist countries that there is no
there is no alternative here that he is
presenting the dichotomy that he is
presenting is that when people are
waiting in bread lines for hours at a
time to try to get just a little bit of
food to survive that's a good thing it
means people are eating but in
capitalist countries there are no bread
lines it must mean that people are
starving except oh nope wait a minute
they're just not waiting because there's
so much food everywhere there's there's
so many opportunities to get food
everywhere that you don't have to wait
in line in the capitalist country in the
United States when you look at the
capitalist company developed during the
height of American capitalism McDonald's
you don't have bread lines you have the
dollar menu you have some of the most
incredible advances in all of human
history the McDouble you have so much
nutrition packed into such a delicious
small little sandwich that you pay $1
for and you don't need to wait in the
bread line you don't need to wait in the
McDouble line for three hours to try to
get it from the government no you can
get it for nothing people have dollars
coming out of their pockets in America
people are lousy with dollars even
homeless people in America are lousy
with dollars one of the troubling things
one of the actual kind of downsides of
going into a fast-food restaurant is
you've got a often in the parking lot or
just outside you got people asking you
for money and you give them money
because that's where they eat that's
where they get their because they can
get a McDouble from one dollar in a
capitalist country this is a beautiful
thing
Bernie Sanders though gets reality
exactly backwards and of course he's
not the only one back to AOC we haven't
talked about the emergency wall funding
measure the national emergency and the
spending bill will cover that very
briefly because AOC doesn't just get
taxes backwards she gets the wall
exactly backwards as well exactly as
backwards as Bernie Sanders gets
socialism and capitalism no matter how
you feel about about the wall you know I
think it's a moral abomination I think
it's like the Berlin Wall
he thinks it's like the Berlin Wall it's
not like the Berlin Wall the Berlin wall
kept people imprisoned in a country the
southern border wall is keeping people
from invading our country illegally it
is not just not like the Berlin wall it
is the exact opposite of the Berlin wall
and just the way that she says it you
know that she has no idea what she's
talking about because she's saying it in
that like um really sort of sardonic way
um and she's not she's not speaking in
any rational way because she doesn't
know she doesn't know anything about
history she doesn't know anything about
economics she doesn't know anything
about politics other than getting
herself elected she does know a thing or
two about that but exactly backwards for
weeks now we've talked about how the
Left doesn't just get the world a little
bit wrong the left view of the world is
not just perverted it is inverted it is
exactly backwards progressivism leftism
socialism or ideologies in which bread
lines are a good thing and abundant
cheap food for everybody is a bad thing
in which keeping people out and keeping
your people safe is exactly the same as
keeping people imprisoned keeping people
locked in of course this is backwards
and it's not just aoc and it's not just
crazy Bernie it's even the allegedly
respectable left-wing Democrat
candidates like Kirsten Gillibrand
I mean this there's a great sense going
on at the motor
we need to be acceptable
and I just want to note that a lot of
these people are indigenous to this
planet and that border so you heard all
the boilerplate it was a little
difficult to hear because that was just
filmed in a restaurant but you hear at
the beginning she says yeah open borders
bring everybody in yeah yeah we need to
take everybody okay that's just
boilerplate democrat stuff but then
listen to the absurdity of this you hear
the interviewer say you know a lot of
the people who are foreign nationals
trying to invade our country are
indigenous to our country and Kirsten
Gillibrand says yes they are
the people who are not here who were not
born here who do not live here who are
not from here they are indigenous to
here which is why we need to let them
come here because they're not here even
though they're here and they're from
here but they're not that is the same
babbling idiocy that we hear from
Alexandria cassio Cortez and Bernie
Sanders now Kirsten Gillibrand might cut
a nicer jib she might be a little more
put together she might talk in a more
sophisticated way but it is the same
incoherence it is the same exact
inversion foreign cannot be indigenous
foreign cannot be native those words are
antonyms they're not synonyms and yet
the left sees no difference it's exactly
backwards and I'll just leave you on
this there was this crazy song that is
making the rounds right now and I don't
I'm not saying it's a billboard number
one song but it is a song that sums up
the left present view on abortion where
you have left-wing governors like
Governor Cuomo in New York
legalizing killing babies as they're
being born and taking away criminal
protections for babies who are being
murdered as they're being born and then
you have governor's like Ralph Northam
in Virginia who are saying that not only
can you kill a baby while it's being
born you should be able to give birth to
the baby let it sit on the table for an
hour and then chop its head off and
that's per thats wonderful that's
women's health that's compassionate
that's comfort
and there's this song now which is a by
some alleged artist named Amanda Palmer
singing about how we ought to have baby
showers for abortions baby showers for
the babies that were about to kill it's
a man they're just waving from London I
know that should go and tomorrow the
third is decision
and I've been on the side of the phone
for a month and I know you're inhaling
and know that I know what you're feeling
life's such a when you have a baby they
throw a party and then when you die they
get together far cry no one's gonna
celebrate you no one's gonna bring you
cake and no one's gonna shower
[Music]
the doctor won't congratulate you no one
on that pavements gonna shadow so that's
a jarring song obviously you hear the
lyrics the song is making a pro-life
argument she doesn't think it's making a
pro-life argument she thinks that she's
suggesting baby showers for people who
kill their babies she's singing about
how it's so wrong that we don't have
baby showers for people who kill their
babies but this is a cry for help in a
perverted culture she's saying she I
know I'm on the phone with you and I
know that you're in hell and you've been
in hell for a month right no one's gonna
celebrate you no one's gonna bring you
cake no one's gonna shower you with
flowers the doctor won't congratulate
you no one on that pavement is gonna
shout at you that your heart also
matters right maybe there is a reason
for that maybe there is a reason why
none of those things will happen maybe
there's a reason why no one's gonna say
oh it's so wonderful all that matters is
you not the baby you just killed
no one's gonna congratulate you on
killing your baby no one's going to
throw you a shower
no one's gonna bring you cake or
celebrate you right why aren't they
going to do that because you've killed
your baby why have you been in hell for
a month because you're thinking about
killing your baby and there's a part of
you that hasn't been totally perverted
by wrong wrong appetites
and even worse ideology and philosophy
there's a part of you that is your
conscience which is telling you that it
is wrong to kill your baby that's why
you've been in hell for a month maybe
there's a reason for all of that
actually the song unintentionally
explains those reasons and then the
whole thesis of the song could be summed
up in that line life's such a word for a
lady dog isn't it life such Oh isn't it
that's the thesis of the song and life
is only that way if you're doing it
exactly the wrong way they're suffering
in life there's hardship this is part of
human nature this is part of a fallen
world but life is always constantly
devoid of joy if you're doing it
backwards if you're doing it the wrong
way
if you have no sense of joy in your life
if you're in hell constant hell it's
because something has gone exactly
backwards something has been inverted
and we're seeing it at all of those
levels political ideology culture and of
course fundamentally when we're talking
about things that matter divine things
metaphysical things religious questions
that's our show tune in tomorrow we'll
have a show tomorrow and then get your
mailbag questions in because then
afterward we'll be going to Notre Dame
and I might get my head chopped off by
an Tifa we'll just have to see check it
out tomorrow see what happens in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt sure I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Danny D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Mick Chien the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19